[Musik]
er ist zu beschäftigt um falten zu
zählen ein alt 68er will dj werden
er hatte viele beruflich verändert
frauen sind immer brav ihnen alles in
die frauen gar nicht als alten in den
jungprofi
wer im alter mit ausgefallenen ideen
unterwegs ist erlebt abenteuer
wer nach dem berufsleben eine zweite
karriere startet weckt in sich neue
kräfte ich fänd ich bin auch ein viertel
weniger welt wurde und jetzt nach 40
jahren wenig mit der echten welt
wer die ideale und gewohnheiten seiner
jugend nicht begraben hat pflegt sie
auch im alter originaltrikot in maxi
wander touren da habe ich das bin ich
hans fischer heiri müller barbara hauser
mann albert nufer vier pensionierte die
unterschiedlicher nicht sein könnten und
doch eines haben sie gemeinsam
[Musik]
die 60er jahre löste eine
gesellschaftliche revolution aus zwänge
und bürgerliche tabus wurden gesprengt
das ist ein film über menschen aus jener
zeit noch heute sind sie alles andere
als zahm
[Musik]
das heimchen am herd diesem frauenbild
aus den 50er jahren wollte barbara
hauser man nie entsprechen
schon als jugendliche kämpfte sie für
die gleichberechtigung mit ihrem
langjährigen lebenspartner für die sie
später eine beziehung auf augenhöhe vor
20 jahren starb an krebs
seit seinem tod ist die 68-jährige
allein steht dann die christen und sie
wird es nachgemacht wird verzichtet
so wie die dinge einfach sind die männer
haben es ihr auch in ihrem beruf als
fotograf in nicht leicht gemacht
sie erkämpfte sich aber den respekt
indem sie jede noch so schwierige
herausforderung an ihre tatkraft ist
auch nach der pensionierung ungebrochen
groß dann fühle ich mich jung
der unterschied diese spielsachen
sammelte die rentnerin für mittellose
familien in albanien eigene kinder hat
sie kalt
sie wollte ungebunden bleiben
joshua ja die garmischer von hus forint
und denn da sagt es ist eine andere
richtung sollte für die ist also das ist
gold führt jeder bergen aber dass ich
gott die schule das jung glaube
[Musik]
für eine fotoreportage kam war browser
man vor zehn jahren zum ersten mal nach
albanien die armut den sie damals sauer
beschäftigte sie sie entschloss sich den
menschen in dem südosteuropäischen land
zu helfen ihr erstes hilfsprojekt
realisierte sie in der hauptstadt tirana
in dieser film und foto akademie ich
habe dir ein gerät aus zürich
mitgebracht sagt die 68-jährige zum
direktor der schule
das fotolabor hat sie mit gebrauchten
apparaturen aus der schweiz eingerichtet
sie leitet auch kurse für fotografie
ohne etwas dafür zu verlangen
immer wenn ein neues abenteuer in
albanien bevorsteht
mit die puppe ist so was wie ein
bodyguard mit dem auto durch und bringt
im abgelegenen gebirge nord albaniens
versucht die schweizerin den abenteurer
tourismus zu fördern
die natur straße führt nach montenegro
und wird auch von schmugglern benützt
die passagiere mit pr und einsam einsam
[Musik]
ja so still
b
[Musik]
obama
nach zwei tagen ist das ziel in
reichweite das tal lipusch mitten im
come and gebühren die menschen hier sind
vollständig auf selbstversorgung
angewiesen die stromversorgung
funktioniert nur selten den winter
hindurch ist das tal von der umwelt
abgeschnitten
[Musik]
das ist nur einer von mehreren
bergbauern denen barbara hauser man
helfen will
sie konnte ihn dazu bewegen in seinem
zuhause werden breakfast für wanderer
anzubieten türkei baut auf seinem
gelände gerade ein haus ausschließlich
für touristen die steine wurde
eigenhändig aus dem fluss unten im tal
bis vor kurzem waren die nord
albanischen alpen ein weißer fleck auf
der karte
dank der schweizerin hat sich das
geändert zusammen mit einem kollegen
schrieb sie einen wanderführer mit
dazugehöriger landkarte natürlichkeit
sind rechtliche kontrolle der zimmer die
luigi in seinem wohnhaus eingerichtet
hat alles ist sauber und der für die
ansprüche westeuropäischer touristen im
unteren stock leben mehrere generationen
auf engem raum die familie befolgte
gesetze des kann nun das alte volksrecht
wird mündlich überliefert und regelt
alle lebensbereiche
die frau die die familie des bräutigams
einheiratet hat vor allem zwei pflichten
sie muss männliche nachkommen zur welt
bringen und die familie bedienen
willkommenstrunk darf sie nicht dabei
sein hofft dass frauen andere stelle
bekommt wir waren sie das
bewerkstelligen ist das natürlich gäste
mit jannik für das was sie machen sauber
ja aber sie blieben es um herz schon
aber sie haben natürlich schon andere
stetig haben dann kann sagen dass ich
wunderbare sache nicht gut und es
gefällt mir und sich dann werde ich
einmal aktiviert
[Musik]
das ist hans fischer er ist 73 jahre alt
kunst interessiert und ein offener geist
dank der 68er protestbewegung fühlte
sich heute viel freier
[Musik]
das ist schon bitter für darüber wären
nämlich entweder das alles so
verkrampfen und heutzutage sind wie die
realität überlegt aber wenig
gesellschaft liberal oder nicht und das
total akzeptiert das ist das problem
sie lebt schon längere zeit ohne partner
ja ja weiter heißt problem
warum konntest du
wieso dann mit denen ich bin nicht der
typ von den blüten stimmtrainerin
hintergrund verhaute und das macht so
die dreifache befinde
hans fischer studierte englisch in den
usa 1968 kehrte er in den aargau zurück
und brachte frischen wind in dieses
ehemalige kloster unter kantonsschule
wettingen unterrichtete er 33 jahre lang
bis zu seiner pensionierung im
klostergarten erinnern sich seine
ehemaligen berufskollegen premier und
bernie graf der konferenz an der
kantonsschule wettingen setzte fischer
ideen um die dem zeitgeist der 68er
entsprachen
er hinterfragte das klassische lehren
und lernen und schaffte den
frontalunterricht ab das immer im radio
access bereich das heißt sie und bis
dahin kommen dass da jetzt einfach
klasse viel größer und sich verschwiegen
und kann schon sagen dass man so mit
genannt diskutiert das ist schon
formieren und die marge in die hand eine
erste emission hat das unterstützt waren
nicht in das team und ich gemacht des
rechts gehweg und kann ich das sehr
schnell realisiert wurde darin sind sich
als lehrer
naja man vom fluss wo sie gange sind die
pension klar den jungs brauchen und das
ist schlimm für mich wieso es braucht ja
wieso kann ihn und uns brand heißt
einfach kann es plattform ihr kreuz
machen
mit 62 gingen frühzeitig in pension ohne
energie und pläne erst zehn jahre später
kam er wegen eines zeitungsartikels auf
eine neue idee
es war ein porträt über eine 70 jährige
die als dj in clubs musik machte das
kann ich doch auch sagte sich fischer
zuerst legte er sich den künstlernamen
dj es zu einer anlehnung an den großen
gatsby ein romanfigur dann begann er
privatunterricht bei einem profi zu
nehmen 14.000 franken kostete ihn bis
jetzt die ausbildung
wissen sie ich ja auf der dj bestenliste
ist sie zwar nicht aufgeführt aber
fischer lernt viel von ihr ich zeig dir
mal was ich jetzt geübt habe zu hause
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das wünsche ich danke 2
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das ist sehr schön zu sehen wie er sich
die musik hingibt und lernen will
ich wünsche mir auch einmal so viel
energie zu haben wenn ich in seinem
alter bin
[Musik]
[Applaus]
manchmal mache ich halt mini ca
ich habe gefühle und das ist mir so
wichtig für mich
es stellt sich natürlich dass ich noch
energie haben das finde ich schade gold
aber wir machen bewusst unbewusst etwas
ist möglich ja das konnte sie aber sich
familien rechnet deshalb ziel dass ich
das mach' es ist hauptsächlich wegen
einfach junge leute können rasch bringen
und sehe dass die eine wand und das
kommt wieder zurück zu mir
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der 70 jährige albert nova ist ein
waschechter althippie die wilden 60er
jahre hat er in bester erinnerung dass
sich jung für ixiaro in montreal bleibt
die kommune mit 12 15 uhr zwei
verschiedene nationen in 15 und 33 und
griffen und den hani hani drogerien
hoffnung paris bip der junge trotz
kristic sie wären diesen
personalausweise gesellschaft daran dass
man überhaupt im versammlungsraum km und
daher im revolution plant im sechser 67
ist relativ theoretisch foren aber wohl
noch her
die macht des f10 montreals city um vor
studenten vor
vor paris gläser daran denkt der hat
noch termine kameraden ihr machen
seine wurzeln hat alba luft im
appenzellischen schönen grund hier
verbrachte er seine jugend jahre an der
sich mit gemischten gefühlen erinnert
vater und mutter führten den ochsen
mitten im dorf oft gab es zank denn
albert passte dich zu recht ins
bürgerliche elternhaus
wir ihn noch zum schlafen nach kalte der
kapelle und die besitzer oder nur leise
das hat sie prägt ich denke da ich jetzt
so wie die familie und die wirtschaft
gewachsen die macht das einfach mitnimmt
wurden beim freiberger und den jo
nagasaki immer glaubt man fertige haus
von seinen reisen durch den
amerikanischen kontinent ketten ufer
1970 in die schweiz zurück als der
querdenker dann in den 80er jahren in
die politik einstieg widmete ihm die
rundschau ein porträt albert nova ist 45
jahre alt 1 textilkaufmann heute land
und gelegenheitsarbeiter wir es
offiziell im pass heißt nova ist auch
weltenbummler friedens und öko
demonstrant und seit kurzem gemeinderat
in st gallen
er vertritt die grünen alternativen im
st galler stadtparlament abgekürzt gras
ich probiere erlebnis ein nomadenleben
führte er übernachtete in telefonkabinen
abbruchhäusern oder wie hier in einem
alten schuppen
20 jahre lang prägte nufer als grüner
die politik im kanton st gallen
zuerst als stadtparlamentarier später
als kantonsrat ohne wahlkampf zu
betreiben erzählt die er stets
spitzenresultate der einen und heimliche
den opel gibt risse und saargebiet die
welt die wahl mit auch wie fehlende die
elektromobile gemacht da und die anderen
blieben im auch karriere ist er angenehm
sein rücktrittschreiben verfasste er
2009 zu diesem zeitpunkt hatte sich nur
für längst über die parteigrenzen hinweg
respekt verschafft sich sehr wertvolle
paar songs sie
der wollte argumentiert gerät beim orion
konventionelle gedanken aber riesch ein
seehund mit herzblut engagiert nimmt der
70-jährige den besen zur hand ist das
für ihn keine arbeit sondern philosophie
mit inbrunst arbeitete er bis zu seiner
pensionierung als straßen vischer
vermischt 1000 traumjob sie die jedem
wetter france und oderberg personen mit
dem material der striche zelle und nur
teilzeit also dass meine sie wirklich
ernst
ja ja
warum ich aufgehört haben mit land und
gleichheits arbeiter wie die neue
spiderman tobey und haben wir sein
fester wohnsitz und verbessern sie
kommen als fester kreis nicht ein
schwacher ständer machen ohne maschine
und russen nur mit 60 haben im vertrag
die maschine muss beginnen mit wie ihr
technisches tor würde jede zwei chrysler
und besser wenn ich wieder kaputt oder
machten lärm und das macht ein viertel
kg dievini wohn geschäfts nachträglich
baut aber mehr fällt darunter auch ein
empfang geeignet traf sich mit ganz
wenig genossen haben sie warnt das gar
nicht mal die heilige mini ruhe der zur
kathedra fernsehkrimis gehört dass ich
mit honig ich schaue mir richtig wohl da
als erstes profi-team möbel so sieht
freilich wenig reiter alles immer
verschiedene plastiksack darin räumt und
alibi und unterhosen
das sind alles dort t shirts da sind
sagt ich brauche dich oder stühle somit
trinken alle lieb ich darum war nicht
nur das schöne match das ich sehe weg
wenn du den namen bis 100 eine brücke
damit die enev grenzt das ich schließe
dich und oder ede becker
und wenn ich mir war sehr bequem zum
esse und trinke er freundin hanna im
moment nur via stopp-loss pensionsalter
russ das heißt du nicht immer wieder
abbauen und eschen strike und
verdächtige
also das ist eigentlich der grund zwar
unter sie dass sie jetzt migranten und
kindern
ja ich war zwar meine freundinnen immer
zu beginn den geliebten teilte die nada
vater wie sohn nach hinter werde
und wenn
ein besseres rasch mehr ruhigstellung
drei problem
aprimo ferrari-verantwortlichen boni und
viel ich dich ja auch so dass sich die
einzel war der körper fortpflanzen und
bieten andere garten geist wieder in vor
seiner ein zimmer wohnung gibt es eine
kleine kochgelegenheit einen kühlschrank
braucht er nicht da wo es zunächst
ergriff bei videos oder salami berechne
bier ist es dort angriffe
nein da sind die rechte vom cato hier
daher bis trocken sind und noch eine in
kompost damit dem krieg mag ich zwei
drei mal so viel regen um tonlose die
andere drogen da nämlich eigentlich
nicht und wenn hätte man das er erlebt
und überlebt aber wenn man nicht frei
seine kollegen sind mit ihm älter
geworden aber noch immer treffen sie
sich am selben ort wie damals als sie
noch jung war
so
[Musik]
die hippie-kultur wird hier immer noch
gelebt sie sind aussteiger die sich dem
leistungsdruck der gesellschaft entzogen
haben
jetzt pensioniert und die hmm lecker so
viel verschiedenes gemacht
ich mache ich nur wenn der druck und
wenig vermögen aufbruch die stimmung
wieder geld verdienen und wenn der nasa
wichtige projekt mobil machen
trabi machen
in albanien haben barbara hauser mann
und ihr einheimischer begleiter einen
schweißtreibenden tag vor sich die
rentnerin will das kennt gebirge
ausländischen touristen zugänglich
machen
[Musik]
die 68-jährige überprüft über das gps
die wanderrouten die sie sich ausgedacht
hat
[Musik]
ja wo stehe ich
ja
[Musik]
barbara hat vor zwei jahren mit dem
markieren von wanderungen begonnen
zuvor gab es hier überhaupt keine
markierten wege
für uns ist diese arbeit sehr wertvoll
und wir hoffen dass schon bald touristen
bauen ihr engagement ist mit viel
idealismus verbunden denn geld verdient
sie keines nur gerade spesen und
material werden hier von einem
italienischen hilfswerk bezahlt das in
albanien entwicklungsarbeit leistet die
rüstige rentnerin will die bergler zur
selbsthilfe animieren dass jetzt die
wahl markiere machen miteinander und das
ist nach zwei wochen
damit meint sie nur erst einmal das
gebiet rund um la push danach will
barbara hauser man in einem anderen teil
des payment gebirges aktiv werden
die unermüdliche einsatz ist inzwischen
auch den albanischen medien aufgefallen
es macht das ist ja ein gescheiter und
dann ist da die nach größe der portionen
sind
das hat das man macht das das erfolg hat
und dass er serviert wird
[Musik]
[Applaus]
elizabeth lee auch das 80
das ist immer ein pc aufbruch immer
wieder bis neues papiere immer wieder
eine pizza abenteuer angst vor großer
langweiler
ich bin glücklich dass konventionen
immer so start in die ferien
dass ich jetzt als ältere menschen musik
machen wenn der junge und sich natürlich
schon blüht störe da aber im großen und
ganzen akzeptiert mich also wenn ich
jetzt das machen und das will ich
natürlich ist ganz wunderbar es das war
in früheren jahren
so kann die in die nation
guten abend meine damen und herren 24
jahre lang moderierte heiri müller die
tagesschau so sind jahre vergangen und
viele von ihnen sind mit mir ein
tüchtiger stück älter geworden
jetzt möchte ich mit musik noch einmal
ein neues kapitel aufschlagen
vielen dank für ihr interesse ja für die
zuneigung die ich oft spürte ich wünsche
ihnen wo immer sie auch sind alles gute
vor fünf jahren ließ sich der jurist mit
doktortitel frühzeitig funktionieren um
seine große leidenschaft auszuleben
[Musik]
das ganz große geschäft ist die musik
veh nicht aber das ist ihm egal
er will einfach zeit haben für das was
sie ihm freude macht doch der freiraum
den er sich geschaffen hat wirkt auch
schattenseiten
[Musik]
er ist schnell langweilig ich muss
aufpassen dass ich nicht abstürze luther
lang will ich mache alles damit sie mir
nicht langweilig wird
musik ist natürlich wunderbar und als
instrument zum das verhindere ich dass
er gerne reise und wenn es mir dann
gleich immer nur langweilig wie den ton
ist der wahnsinn ist eher ungern lassen
als jan fields viel energie für den
senior ich sehe mich aber gar nicht so
ich denke hier das senior gefühl ich
müsste ich das aber das wird ein das
bedeutet dass man seit ich mit mir
exakte schranke mich gibt's auch ein
name mit elektrischer schranken auf mit
seit du bist und so weitermachen
entschieden
ex- tagesschau moderator dr
aber dann wirklich im grunde ja auch
keine musik machen mit der gebürtige
nigerianerin ruht ist heidi seit 20
jahren verheiratet
das zuhause am stadtrand von zürich ist
ihre insel für zweisamkeit
die 58-jährige steht voll hinter ihrem
mann der so ganz anders ist als sie ich
brauche das rampenlicht nicht im
gegensatz zu ihm er hat schon früher
viel aufmerksamkeit erhalten und er hat
sie auch heute damit der musik die er
macht das ist ihm wichtig er ist heute
sicherlich glücklicher und entspannter
als früher
er hat mir zeit seine leidenschaft
auszuleben er ist glücklich
[Gelächter]
als welt also wenn man das wort wilder
wein verwandelt eigentlich passt das
relativ gut so wie sehr die jungen
wilden und dann gibt es noch die
autowelt und ich gehören wird so der
alten bildern
wird
charlie matter und heidi müller eben
auch musik kann als alba musiker und
erklärt alfred jacobi der ex moderatorin
ist mit seinem vierten album auf promo
tour für mich sicherlich zwischen tories
oder videokamera österreich bühne mensch
war ich bis jetzt nie zurück liegt und
von dem taxi muss ich einfach sagen das
fenster wunderbares kapitel sehr
spannend als journalist können schaffen
als moderator prof und jetzt ist das
dritte kapitel im leben auf das ist die
musik und ich bin eigentlich voll
erfüllt einen film auf der haut jacobi
und viel erfolg mit dem album mit der
tournee der aufhängung harry müller
für ihn sind sie selber der export
landrut ist umgekehrt brauchen sie aber
bis die öffentlichkeit ja ich würde
sagen ich habe ich mich gewöhnt dass
mich wo die klage bezieht ruhig wenn es
einfach vor einem club der anders nicht
mehr wahr
also ich denke schon im islam besteht
stark und zwar schon sichtlich eine
besetzung immer der witters glücklich
damit mehr sich auseinandergesetzt
ich kenne mich mögen und das im großen
und ganzen alles so sagen und das war es
böses um könne es kommt ja noch das böse
ahnungen ich bin mir den bewusst ich
kann nicht einfach mit den musikerinnen
art der aufmerksamkeit mehr verlängern
und ich sollte man ihm sagen dass sie
gegen diese unmenschliche das ist
wirklich sehr schön
und darum war es also sage ich genieße
es einfach noch so lange das ist durch
eine der stets wegen ihrer bescheidenen
art bewunderte was eine gotte dort im
gegensatz zu ihm suchte sie nie die
öffentlichkeit selbstlos war sie ein
vorbild das heil deshalb in diesem film
zu wort kommen lassen wollte doch kurz
vor dem geplanten besuch starb die
betagte hier auf dem hof im luzernischen
wie kon
und so wird der ausflug einen
kondolenzbesuch baidu ließ tochtermarke
bäuerin martha müller und ihre familie
lebten bis zuletzt mit oli unter einem
dach sie starb friedlich im alter von 97
jahren und den dank aller muss man auf
der andere sie täglich eigentlich
dankbar sie froh sie dass er so lange
könne
ein dritter ich schließe mit
schwiegertochter taxi und tüchtig
gerückt
ich hätte vor ich darf sie sich
praktisch nie erhitzen
das ist das geschenk das ist ein
trockener bisher glücklos
jeder lebt in der angst vor einsamkeit
die haut aus ich habe das noch nicht so
recht vorstellen obwohl das probiere
immer so viele leute um mich omaha und
immer noch nie so
regelmäßig kommen auf mich zu also bis
jetzt ist es noch nicht schwierig nicht
ein samt sich aber ich habe mir das aber
sehr wohl vorstellen
ich kann sagen einsamkeit macht mehr
richtig angst also wirklich angst vor
der kamera sagte dass die aktivität wo
sie herrn david dazu jene die einsamkeit
vertreten
ich denke alles was wir machen gott sehr
darum dass mehr soziale wesen sind das
meer schöner möglichst lang in dem laden
in den stau und freud gar und freude und
das gilt für mich auch es gibt nichts
schöneres für mich im moment passt eben
ein konzert könne
erstens applaus schaue mir selber aber
dennoch serie andere lied freut dass die
musik ab gehabt und so und ich habe das
gerät dazu dass soziale und wenn man das
einfach nur traurig sind wir einfach zur
einsamkeit verdammt am schluss und wenn
wir das noch alles wissen
ich weiß es bis jetzt nicht
[Musik]
alt werden und der bei jungen bleiben
ist mit arbeit verbunden arbeit an
körper und geist
was ist der grund dass es sich mit
chinesischen und setzte er findet das
hatte danach blieb der geistig fit und
ich weiß dass möglichst land sie für
mich ein einmarsch in die wurst ein
problem geht das wenn ich ab handelt
wird verlegt und wenn ich das flugzeug
möglichst lang geistig und physisch ist
das schade gut
zum glück bin ich meine amtlich warum
zurück ich meine dass ich da dass man
sie sandte und danach muss man auch viel
schöner ist von abschließend sein zimmer
und ich hoffe dass ich mich aber gut
kann abschluss der sich netzwerke da sie
selber machen oder die edition ist für
sich eine kakao
die beiden freundinnen sizilianische und
barbara hauser man haben schon manchen
sturm gemeinsam überstanden
st
sollten
das leipzig tag und nacht und wenn david
lepsch musterklage machen
übermorgen die und die kommenden tag und
nacht die schweiz welcher überredet
haben aus angst habe ich kein geld die
malerisch frank oder ja die haben mir
die eine schnelle regelung aber auch
erfüllt seine lungen heute lieber mit
frischer luft statt mit dem brauch von
cannabis die st anna kommen gerne wenn
ihr stadt original aus an dem wilden
leben erzählt eingeladen wurde er von
schülerinnen im zehnten schuljahr
projekt bierstube grill nicht staaten in
afrika der asiens riesige städte an
statt ex milliardenteuren quercus der
wowi ob die neben bringt sie ist diese
zitate facebook genau ist und genau hier
pro jahr damit umzugehen und die
harmonie in den computer
[Applaus]
in wenigen minuten wird heiri müller mit
seiner band auf der bühne stehen
wie nervös
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich bin inzwischen der 73 jährige
bekommt zum ersten mal die chance in
einem angesagten club sein können zu
zeigen
man merkt dass du beim publikum mit auf
wunsch müsste ich die kleider stoppen
und dann wäre von dieter polte 100
ich denke mal dass ich so gut oder
[Musik]
mehr
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die massen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die sechziger jahre machten sie zu dem
was sie heute sind
im geiste sind sie jung geblieben
gaddafis
so kann man getrost als werden
[Musik]
[Applaus]